it is seven o'clock good to see you this
morning so we have had a winter warning
we're being told that plan d is ready to
roll if the covert situation gets worse
but when exactly is worse with
scientists warning
of a peak by december we'll be asking
the health secretary sergeant javit is
on the show shortly the shadow working
pension secretary jonathan reynolds also
with us a little later on five ways to
make sure your mashed potato is out of
this world
tip number one when you cut your spuds
for match
uh also this morning the tick-tock chef
who's not let her covered redundancy
stop her from becoming an online
sensation we'll see what she's cooking
up for us at 20 to 10. but also on the
show
we will be talking to the mission
impossible star degree scott about how
he's hoping to make it his mission
possible to help countries face up to
the water crisis facing millions of
people it is wednesday the 15th of
september
covid's case warning as scientists say
people heading back to work after
restrictions ease could drive up
infections causing a peak by december
a diplomatic spat as the chinese
ambassador is banned from uk parliament
[Music]
no idea who this is
so how can they message me
a spike in sexual crimes against
children that start online one woman
tells us how a game she played as a
teenager ended in violent sexual assault
he was
very
abrupt
and
told me to take all my clothes off
and i was terrified and didn't know what
to do
living in fear our special correspondent
alex crawford reports on what's
happening to women in kabul one month on
from the taliban takeover
and it could be you the mexican
government is to give away a house used
by the drug kingpin el chapo in a
lottery
[Music]
morning all we are heading into the
winter months with a plan a and a plan b
to fight covet but at what point might
the government implement the tougher
measures with some scientists warning
that people heading back to work after
restrictions ease could drive up
infections and cause cases to peak by
december we'll be asking the health
secretary sajid javid who's on the show
shortly but first let's take you through
the plans
themselves uh well the prime minister
confirmed
that the vaccine booster program will
begin for the over 50s and for those
under 50 who are more at risk the
government has also accepted the
recommendation for 12 to 15 year olds to
be vaccinated at protection like face
masks will still be suggested
in crowded places
tougher restrictions in england though
could still be implemented under what
the prime minister has called plan b
face coverings could become legally
mandated once again covert passports
could be required in some venues and
work from home advice could be
reintroduced our community's
correspondent lisa holland reports
in this city where the first vaccine was
given as the government announced its
winter vaccine plan we went to meet a
rock band to discuss living with covid
who else but the vaccines performing at
the empire in coventry on a five-week
tour
they're reveling in being back in the
spotlight but if the latest strategy
doesn't work some concerts and large
events face further restrictions nobody
wants to contemplate the lights going
out again
you know it's been really difficult like
we rely on connection and community and
packing
hundreds of thousands of people into
tight spaces like this that's you know
that's sort of our bread and butter it's
like the bread and butter of our crew
that come on tour with us and all that
sort of thing so you know we haven't
really
really haven't worked for the last 18
months it's been really tough do you
ever regret calling yourself the
vaccines
do we have a regret calling ourselves
the vaccines you know it hasn't been too
bad the odd the odd dad joke here and
there but nothing uh nothing too bad
in coventry last december 91 year old
margaret keenan became the first person
in the uk to receive a vaccine outside
of clinical trials since then all adults
have been offered a jab
for sarah jane hennessy running a fancy
dress shop in the city is a family
affair which is why she's embracing her
daughter who's nearly 12 having the
vaccine in the interests of those who
are more vulnerable i do think that
probably 20 30 years ago this is how
parents might have felt about
the measles mumps from rubella
whatever sort of things we've had to
have for vaccinations i think covert is
here to stay
gladys trickett is 104 years old and
survived getting covered but nursing
homes like the belvedere in coventry are
bracing for the second winter of the
pandemic
they haven't lost anyone here to the
virus and the booster program can't come
soon enough i think it's wonderful news
i think it's going to really really
bring some more security and safety to
the lives of everybody that live here um
it's been a long time since everybody's
had their second
dose which was in april this year so
they've gone six months
young or old booster or first jab the
government believes getting a vaccine is
the way for normal life to continue this
winter lisa holland sky news coventry
i'm very pleased to see we're joined in
the studio once again by the health
secretary sergeant javed minister really
good to see you this morning good
morning um look i think i think people
will be reassured to hear that the
government does have a plan b as we move
into uh autumn winter maybe it's
slightly surprised that we're calling it
plan b but to have one is is certainly
advantageous but given the briefing we
had from the chief medical officer
yesterday given the minutes from sage
from a week ago which were released
yesterday warning of 7000
hospitalizations a day
why are we not moving to plan b
immediately
well look what we set out yesterday were
our plans to manage covid over the
autumn in the winter we know that's the
time of year that you know covered 19
likes and other seasonal viruses like
flu so i think it's right for government
to reassure people that we have planned
for this our first line of defense
against covid remains our hugely
successful vaccine program that's
complemented by amazing new treatments
by our juggernaut of our testing system
our world-class surveillance system and
this is all working and that's allowed
us to make the gains that we've seen
over the last few months and return
you're almost to normal and alongside
that by the way we are also going to
have the biggest flu vaccination program
this country has ever seen so we need to
work and continue to plan for that we
also want to increase vaccine uptake
that's going to help over autumn and
winter and that's why yesterday i also
announced that we're going ahead with a
booster program for some 30 million
people starting next week and we're also
offering vaccines to 12 and 15 year olds
so i think taken together
this can protect the gains that we've
made we've got to remain cautious of
course but i think that's a good plan a
all of which all of which is entirely
laudable but we we knew all of that the
question remains why are we not moving
to more stringent measures now if we do
nothing if behavioral patterns do not
change if action continues then we are
on track to see hospitalizations
increasing significantly in the next
couple of weeks no i think it's i think
you might be there referring to the sage
report that you just mentioned obviously
there's other reports and things and
it's right that experts are looking at
what's happening and trying to come up
with their best guess of where things
might go based on certain assumptions
now my job as the health secretary and
other ministers is to take all of that
together and and make the best decision
and that we can you know i remind you
that back when we made the step four
decision there were also uh experts
saying that you know case rates are
going to surge to 200 000 the
hospitalization hospitalization's gonna
go two to three hundred to three
thousand a day don't do it but we have
to listen to that but eventually make
what we think is the right decision and
there's no there is no risk-free
decision but i think what we've
announced in terms of this plan is is
well thought through it's the act of a
responsible government to set out this
is our plan this is what how we're going
to protect the gains but just in case
things are not quite as we would want
them to we've got to have another plan
and get that ready to completely agree
that there are no risk-free options but
there are riskier options and there are
there are options which are less risky
it does rather feel that we're in the
same situation we were this time last
year when sage were again warning that
there needed to be some kind of
intervention the government dithered and
dallied for two months before we got the
lock down and we know what happened
december and january in terms of
hospitalizations and deaths yes and i
think the big big difference this is
huge
are the vaccines i mean the vaccines are
working we know that they've already
stopped some 125 000 deaths some 140 000
hospitalizations some 25 million
infections and that is why we also want
more people as part of our plan to take
the vaccine there's some six million
adults out there that still haven't had
a single jab
and they may well have been better
spending the summer trying to get as
many of those vaccinated as possible and
that's and i think it's great that we
have got to 81 of adults having
headaches colleagues have always said
what did previously say that the
vaccination program was the way out of
this and clearly that's not the case
anymore well i think if we can if we all
look at where we are today versus even
at the start of this year we've made
huge progress and the answer the reason
for that is the vaccines now it's not
just the vaccines on their own we can't
just rely on vaccines and that's why the
new treatments that we have in the nhs
is hugely important as part of our
defense our testing system where our
offer of a free test you know that is
identifying some quarter of the positive
cases that we see on a daily basis and
so when we get those people to isolate
that helps protect not just them but
those around them our surveillance
system it's the best in the world and
how we now can better look out for and
track any new variants and especially
those that might concern us so you're
taken together that's a very strong
package that said and if they are
implying this i would agree with this
bit is that we need to make sure that
we've also got plans in place just in
case for example there is some a new
variant of concern let's say highly
infectious has some kind of vaccine
escape capability we've got to prepare
for that and have things ready to go
just in case so it is a new variant the
the trigger point for a move to plan no
i would i i wouldn't i mean a new and
dangerous new variant you know would be
of of course a huge significant concern
but it doesn't there could be other
issues so for example
you know what happens in the nhs is
going to be hugely important to me to
the whole country making sure that we
don't get to a position again where the
nhs becomes unsustainable but what
happened hospitalizations would be
unacceptable well i don't i think we're
going to have to look at a number of
measures which we already do working
closely with our friends in the nhs so
of course that would be the level of
hospitalization it will be the pressures
on a e the pressures on the workforce so
we'd have to take all of these together
and and obviously on a
you know daily basis you know talking to
our friends in the nhs to see uh how
they are coping with pressures now we
know at a winter time even in a normal
winter without coving it can get very
tough uh for the nhs now we've got a
layer covered on top of that and
and going into this winter i think we
just want to be as best prepared as we
possibly can do you now accept that you
were wrong to say back in june that the
relaxation of restrictions was was
irreversible i mean messaging at times
like this particularly in a public
health crisis is all important your
words will have had an effect on
people's behavior i i look i like anyone
else i want the as we remove measures i
want it to be irreversible but as we've
said now i would say that you said it
was a reversible do you accept no that
you were wrong to state that
was wrong i want them to be irreversible
and i think that you know what what i
was expressing then and what many people
have expressed a desire that we just
keep moving forwards that we don't have
to go backwards into measures that we'd
wish we'd just said goodbye to but
i think we just have to be
remaining uh cautious and i think what
we set out yesterday as a government uh
our plans uh to to keep up with the
vaccine program to keep up with the
testing i think these are the good solid
measures but we've got to continue to
work together as a country to protect
the gains that we've made sure but i
think the problem the problem is that
the messaging seems to veer between you
know one point in the day completely
cautious the other end of the day come
completely optimistic but let's just
take one of the one of the aspects from
from pioneers as outlined by the prime
minister yesterday the advice that we
should now be wearing masks in in
crowded places masks in in indoor
situations mass when mass when people
requested all this according according
to chris whitty when you and your
cabinet colleagues met yesterday to
discuss and sign off on what the prime
minister said
how many of you were wearing masks you
can take a look at the picture that
we've got the the number 10 released
yesterday that they chose this picture
there's basically 38 to 40 people in
that room poorly ventilated not one
person is wearing a mask on the day that
you advise us to wear masks in
situations like that and that is uh
perfectly consistent with what the prime
minister said yesterday and what i said
yesterday because what we said was that
people should uh consider wearing masks
in crowded places when they are with
strangers when they are with people that
they are not normally spending their
time conservative back benches to be
wearing masks at pmq's later no they're
not they're not strangers you know this
is they the set of back benches whether
they're in parliament in the chamber
themselves itself or in their other
meeting rooms and things you're not
catching they're saying
it's it's not it's it you have to take
measures that are appropriate
for the the prevalence of kobit at the
time and and with the with the measures
that we've taken with vaccines with
testing with surveillance and and
sensible use of masks when required and
you know as we've suggested yesterday
which has been perfectly consistent by
the way with what we said at the time we
entered step four we took that step and
we're in the what i said at the time of
that mask with the prime minister said
that hasn't changed and so that
messaging has been consistent throughout
and it's important uh that we we set out
as we have in this plan about how we can
work together to protect these gains do
you think more or less people would wear
masks if they saw you wearing them
around the cabinet table
i i think look of course people are
influenced by others but every
individual should make the decision
based on the advice that they're given
and in the situation they find
themselves in at the time i mean
there is plenty of misinformation and
disinformation around it and as your
absolute right to point out that people
will take their lead from others nicki
minaj made some pretty baseless claims
on social media i'm not going to ask
about those specifically but i do wonder
whether or not you feel the social media
companies are doing enough that tweet by
nicki minaj remains up this morning i
don't want to draw attention to such
ridiculous tweets but
the
people that are in in the public eye you
know whether they are a a a celebrity or
a politician or whatever they are they
should be very careful uh with their
language and and certainly to not be
spending on truths and i think what the
what the chief medical officer said was
absolutely right i i think everyone
would agree with you that people in in
public positions should be very very
careful with their language i do wonder
then what you make of the comments that
have come to light michael gove not when
he was a student as some suggested but
when he was in his 20s he used the term
fuzzy wuzzis to describe black people
what is going on in this government what
should happen to him look i i know my i
don't know anything about that
particular report whether he made it
before but he did not marx at the time i
don't know whether he did or did not say
that what i do know i didn't know
michael gove in his 20s but i do know
him now and i think you'd find it hard
to come across anyone in the government
that is uh so inclusive and and
celebrates the kind of britain that we
are today sure but but if a member of
the english cricket first 11 had made
those remarks in his 20s he'd be ejected
from the side and he'd be suspended from
cricket it feels like the bar for
acceptable language for a minister for
the crown is lower than that for a guy
who hits a ball with a bat
professionally look i i don't agree with
you look i as i said i've i've told you
with my experience with michael gove i
think we're lucky to have him and
everything that he does in in government
makes a huge difference every day but in
terms of those particular remarks
obviously i didn't know him in his 20s
i'm not even familiar with that
particular report but you could try and
invite him on your program and see what
he has to say except you won't be drawn
on that i do want then want to conclude
on the decision by by the speaker of the
house of commons to in essence ban the
the chinese ambassador from speaking
from a diplomatic from a political
standpoint do you agree with that
decision well first of all it's a
decision for parliament but government
decisions
i i think that
given that the the chinese government
has banned british parliamentarians i
find that unacceptable there is
absolutely wrong for the chinese
government to ban british
parliamentarians and you for calling out
the gross human rights violations that
take place in that country
and and that's the yeah and i can see
why parliament represented by the
speaker and the lord speaker might have
made this decision
uh minister great to have you on the
program you've got a very busy day so we
will let you go thank you very much
thanks for having me
uh some breaking news that's just
emerged it watched in the last couple of
minutes in fact the uk's latest latest
monthly inflation figures are out our
economics editor
ed conway joins us with that ed bring us
up to date please
yeah really striking numbers from the
office for national statistics this this
is inflation it's a measure of just how
fast prices around the economy are
rising you kind of average shopping
basket worth of goods and services and
it's risen very fast indeed over the
course of the last month let me just
show you what we're talking about here
this line shows you that consumer price
index that's basically the measure we're
talking about it's the annual increase
as i say so so when it's very high
obviously that means that your the goods
that you're buying in the shops are
going up very fast and what you can
probably see i'll add on this latest
month's worth of numbers august
it was 3.2 percent uh in august and
that's significant for a few reasons
first of all the bank of england has a
target of 2 so that's now way above the
bank of england's target the governor
will have to explain what's going on
what the bank is going to do about it
whether they're going to change interest
rates as a result we'll expect that uh
in their next set of minutes potentially
next month secondly you're talking about
it may not look like it there but first
of all that's the highest level that
we've seen since kind of around 2011 but
secondly the change month on month so
last time around it was two percent uh
up from two percent to three point two
percent that is the biggest month or
month change that we've seen in this
measure since it came around since 1997
so you're talking about a lot of
volatility in the prices of the goods
and services we pay for on a
month-to-month basis and that is
something that perhaps you've noticed
but what is causing that we'll have a
quick look at this
these are the different contributions
and obviously there's a lot of things
here but look by far and away it was
prices at restaurants and hotels that
are up a lot since last year what was
happening this time last year it was eat
out to help out so prices went down a
lot last year they're coming back again
this year so a lot of people the bank of
england included will probably say this
is likely high as it is to be quite
temporary
ed thanks very much indeed
well as you had just heard a couple of
minutes ago during our chat with the
health secretary there is something of a
diplomatic spat brewing the chinese
ambassador to the uk has been banned
from our parliament the speaker saying
that it is not appropriate for him to
enter because of sanctions china has put
on british mps who spoke out about
weaker human rights issues
the ambassador was clearly hoping for
slightly better relations though here he
was in week one of his new job
i look forward to working with the
british government in france in all
sectors
to increase engagement and communication
enhance mutual understanding
and promote mutually beneficial
cooperation between our two peoples
uh let's bring in our asia correspondent
tom cheshire who's in shanghai this
morning good to see you again tom how's
this playing out where you are
yeah well there's not a lot of mutual
understanding right now is there i mean
just to give you the previous on this um
earlier in this year the uk government
sanctioned
four chinese officials for what it
called gross human rights abuses in
xinjiang the region
north northwest china where up to a
million people are estimated by the u.n
to have been put in detention centers
china fired back with its own sanctions
not against uk officials but against
think tanks academics lawyers but also
politicians including senior
conservatives like syrian duncan smith
and tom tuganda and that had been the
case for a while what changed was that
the chinese ambassador he's relatively
new i think he was making those remarks
back in june uh mr genzer gwan uh he was
supposed to go to parliament to give a
speech to a cross parliamentary group
which is a lot more friendly to china
than most parliamentarians um people
spotted this and said well it wouldn't
be appropriate it would be an insult to
parliament for him to come there while
there are still these sanctions in place
and you might think that's fair enough
you're not going to go to someone's
house for tea if you're sanctioning them
at the same time but the chinese
ambassadors reacted very quickly very
furiously as well he said uh in a
statement that this is a short-sighted
reckless and cowardly move we despise
and strongly condemn this
so very very strong words there what's
interesting though is there is a
distinction being made between uk
parliament which has been given china a
lot of trouble people stand up and say
things that are displeasing to china and
the uk government which isn't mentioned
in this we're awaiting further reaction
from beijing at its daily press
conference at 3 p.m local about an
hour's time from now
and tom just the other day we were
talking about north korean missile
launches reports of some more
yeah like buses you wait a long time
then we've got two launches at once this
is a different sort of launch from what
was reported over the weekend that was a
cruise missile it was announced by
korean state media this is different
because it was announced by japanese and
south korean militaries they both
spotted this which indicates it is a
bigger missile we don't know how big we
don't know whether it violates those un
security resolutions but i think what
we're seeing is a concerted effort by
north korea to remind the world of its
presence those two missile launches a
big military period in pyongyang and the
news from the u.n last month that it had
restarted its nuclear reactor there are
nuclear negotiators from u.s japan south
korea all meeting in tokyo so that's
timing and also wang e the chinese
foreign minister is in south korea so
while this is all happening i think
north korea is reminding the world about
its capability and about its threat
tom many thanks indeed
uh plenty coming up on the show this
morning at half past dr david nabarro
from the world health organization will
once again be joining us at this time to
examine the government's winter color
virus strategy
has social care become the forgotten
sector in the government's winter covert
plan i'll be hearing from a care home
boss sam longhood at quarter two
and then at five past eight i'll be
speaking to labour's working pension
secretary at shadow working pension
secretary i should say jonathan reynolds
giving us his view on the government's
covered winter plans
the nspcc wants the new online safety
bill going before parliament to include
criminal sanctions for social media
companies which failed to protect
children from sexual abuse on their
websites there's been a rise of 78 in
online crimes against children in just
four years our home editor jason farrell
spoke to one young woman about her
experience of being abducted and
sexually assaulted after being groomed
online
danielle has waived her anonymity to
warn others about what happened to her
when she was just 14. what started with
a child's online game ended in violent
sexual assault there were virtual world
websites
and it was on one of these websites
that
it all started basically so there was
private chat rooms um and it started off
as just a friendly conversation
um obviously asked how old each other
and he said he was around 16.
but the man not child john graham
edwards was actually in his late 40s he
groomed danielle in the online games
chat room arranged to meet her then
abducted her taking her to a forest he
was
very
abrupt
and
told me to take all my clothes off
and i was terrified and didn't know what
to do i didn't know where i was
um and he was quite far away from home
and i just did what he told me to do
later he repeatedly sexually abused her
a digital game had led to real life
horror and danielle's story is becoming
increasingly common data from 39 police
forces show over 5400 child sexual
offences involving online contact were
recorded in 2016-17
but it rose 78 percent in four years to
over 9700 offenses last year the nspcc
wants to strengthen the draft online
safety bill it does propose criminal
sanctions for companies but the charity
says they're watered down and don't
relate directly to keeping children safe
on their platforms and they want a named
person scheme which would make senior
managers at tech companies personally
liable if a senior manager
consistently and repeatedly fails to
ensure that their platform is
fundamentally safe for children to use
then there should be the backstop of
criminal sanctions the government told
sky news our new laws will be the most
comprehensive in the world in protecting
children online failing firms will face
hefty fines or have their sites blocked
and we will have the power to make
senior managers criminally liable for
failing to protect children
danielle's abuser was imprisoned but
when released he groomed more children
and was convicted again it begins with
these websites it begins with these apps
it begins with the internet
so i think they should be held
accountable for part of this year
as this nspcc campaign conveys it's all
too easy
no idea who this is
so how can make a message awareness and
regulation are the best defense to
protect children
jason farrell sky news
uh some other news this morning and it's
being reported that more than 1
400 dolphins have been killed off the
coast of the pharaoh islands the sea
shepherd conservation society claims it
witnessed the slaughter in esteroid
during the danish territory's
century-old traditional hunt
it claims it's the largest single cull
of dolphins ever recorded worldwide
let's take our usual look at the impact
of climate change on the planet the top
line showing how the uk's power is being
generated 65 currently from fossil fuels
you can see how much warmer the earth is
now than in 1880 when modern records
began 1.234 degrees celsius then at the
figure beneath that the time it will
take uh to get to a rise of 1.5 degrees
celsius a little longer than 11 years
then that large figure at the bottom
there that's the total co2 emissions in
millions of tons
uh you can keep up today with all the
stories affected by climate change on
the daily climate show that's right here
live on sky news every weekday at half
past six
haiti's chief prosecutor has asked a
judge to charge the country's prime
minister ariel henry over the
assassination of the president
uh president joven elmoisi was shot dead
by assassins who stormed his home in the
capital porto prance in july a key
suspect in the assassination allegedly
called the prime minister twice
just hours after the killing
the culture secretary oliver dowden is
expected to outline how channel 4 could
thrive even if it's sold
the department of culture media and
sport is consulting on a possible
privatisation for the company which is
government owned channel 4 has warned
that privatization may cause them harm
the u.s justice department has asked a
federal judge to issue an order to block
texas from enforcing a law banning
abortions from around six weeks
the department argued that the law was
adopted to prevent women from exercising
their constitutional rights the law has
no exceptions for rape or incest well
last week the justice department filed a
lawsuit against the state
the home of mexico's most notorious
gangster is to be given away in the
country's national lottery complete with
its network of escape tunnels uh skies
skies aisha's ahead joins us now aisha
what on earth is going on here and tell
us a little bit more about this well
some person's dream property perhaps not
mine
well it's really intriguing isn't it
this house in question was used by el
chapo back in 2014 it's he was using the
house before he was had to escape after
being surrounded by marines and he
escaped using an underground tunnel in
the bathroom now the house has had some
changes since el chapo was using it it's
had a fresh lick of paint inside and
outside security cameras around the
exterior covering every angle have been
removed and the ton access to the
network of tunnels has been tiled over
in the bathroom the it's valued at over
132 000 pounds now it's not the first
time the government mexican government
have tried to get the property off their
hands it was put up for auction
last year but with no luck no takers
there so that is completely
understandable he el chapo was a
notorious criminal so it's hope that
there will be some success getting the
property off their hands this time
around the national lottery draw will
take place today two million tickets
were available just over nine pounds
each and all proceeds will be going
towards mexico's olympic athletes
aisha many thanks indeed
now the health secretary sergeant javid
has said the government's plan b to
fight covert during the winter will be
brought in to protect the nhs he told me
earlier that the vaccine program is very
successful but trigger factors could be
a dangerous new variant or the nhs being
under strain
it is a new variant the the trigger
point for a move to plan no i wouldn't i
i i wouldn't i mean a new and dangerous
new variant you know would be of of
course a huge significant concern but it
doesn't there could be other issues so
for example
you know what happens in the nhs is
going to be hugely important to me to
the whole country making sure that we
don't get to a position again where the
nhs becomes unsustainable what has to do
hospitalizations would be unacceptable
well i don't i think we're going to have
to look at a number of measures which we
already do
our political correspondent joel pank
joins us in the studio morning joel what
did we learn from the health sector this
morning i thought quite a bit actually
yeah loads of new signs in that
interview with such a javid two things i
think it's important to touch on in
terms of covid one what is the trigger
point for plan b a new dangerous variant
appearing is not in is not enough that
of course would be of concern he says
but there are various different bits of
data hospitalizations
a e
uh capacity as well as how the workforce
are doing that he'd take into account
also seemingly distancing himself from
those sage suggestions that if we don't
act faster more restricted we could see
7 000 cases a day remember of course
when we moved ahead with stage four of
the road map there were warnings of 100
000 cases a day uh so i think that shows
he maybe doesn't uh he'll he'll take
scientific advice with a pinch of salt
the one other thing on this story you
were discussing with tom cheshire about
the chinese ambassador being banned from
the uk parliament sounded like he sort
of agreed with that he didn't say it
quite in those terms but he said he
understood the decision that the
speakers of the commons and lords have
made
joe for now thanks very much indeed
now let's stick with covid19 and the
uk's public health response uh joining
us once again on the programme the world
health organization special envoy for
the global global clovid 19 uh pandemic
response uh dr david navarro dr nabarro
it has been a while i do hope you're
welcome
good morning
it is
it is perhaps it is a perhaps a sign
though the fact that you and i have not
been talking as regularly over the past
few months that perhaps things were were
getting better for a while but the fact
that we're talking once again suggests
as we edge into ottoman winter that
we've all got to start being a little
bit more careful now don't we
well what i think
all this means is that
we're moving into a different way of
seeing covid and the virus it's going to
be with us
for the foreseeable future it's not just
something that's here for today and gone
tomorrow and so that means we have to
become better at dealing with it in the
long term and i think that's what we're
focusing on today this plan a and plan b
and what we're seeing in other countries
as well trying to get organized for the
coming months into autumn and winter
yeah i mean one can one can easily
understand the desire of governments
around the world particularly those of a
center right or or right wing persuasion
not to take away freedoms that they have
given back to their uh back to their
communities but at the same time we have
to be ready to very quickly move from
plan a to plan b don't we
yeah i think so and speed is obvious i
was reading transcripts of some of the
meetings that took place in london
yesterday and i think the point that
i felt was well well carried in the
media is that we've been through this
before and we know as a result of past
experience that acting quickly and
acting quite robustly is the way you get
on top of this virus then life can go on
whereas if you're a bit slower
then it can build up and become very
heavy and hospitals fill up
and then you have to take all sorts of
emergency action so i really like what
uh uk is doing i think this emphasis on
people learning to live with the virus
is is also the right one i think the
only nuance that i would add is that
people always need the help of their
governments and that's why i'm rather
pleased to see that the government is
looking at the different data signals
that will be used to perhaps move us
from one state into another i just hope
there won't be a need for lots more
restrictions because we do indeed as
humanity need to be able to learn to
live with this virus and to hold it away
and stop it from wrecking our lives
but of course dr nobody it isn't a
binary distinction between incredibly
draconian restrictions all the way
through to lockdown and having
absolutely nothing that does feel at the
in the uk at the moment perhaps well in
england let's at least speak about the
responsibility that the prime minister
has in england at least there is there
is a reticence to perhaps even do
something as simple as bringing back in
mandatory wearing of face masks in
public areas i mean from from their
perspective it does seem it's all or
nothing wouldn't you perhaps what you're
saying suggest that they could bring in
a couple of measures
yeah
neil thank you i i i want to really
agree with you on that
and i like the way you put it you see
when we're trying to deal with this
virus we have a number of tools that we
can use
and from our perspective as public
health people we don't make distinction
between tools in terms of whether or not
people like them and so
if we believe that wearing face masks
will make a difference to the risk
if we believe that being more than a
meter or so apart from each other will
make a difference then we're going to
recommend it now what i've noticed is
that in some countries
the actual act of wearing a mask or
a
accepting some of the restrictions that
kobe requires is seen as a sort of
political activity you do it if you
belong to one party and you don't do it
if you uh belong to another i want to be
very clear this virus has no political
affiliations at all
the facts are the same
whatever you party you vote for and so i
think we're going to continue as health
people just say here's the situation and
please
follow the advice regardless of whether
you are on that side or the other side
of the political spectrum i like the way
you put it
i'm very pleased to hear you say that
doctor um i do want to just quit quickly
question though about
the expansion of our vaccination program
on the one hand of course we are hearing
that the boosters will be offered from
next week to those who are over 50 which
does suggest of course that there is a
waning efficacy we understand that to be
the case but but more than that the
united kingdom
catching up i would suggest with with
other parts of the u with other parts of
europe in terms of vaccinating the 12 to
15 year olds will be a bit slow to that
well i i want to be clear
as far as i'm concerned this vaccine is
great for saving the lives of people who
get a disease what it does is it reduces
the severity and it stops you from from
dying
and it's a most wonderful gift and i
actually think that we should be using
the quite scarce amounts of vaccine in
the world today to make sure that
everybody at risk wherever they are is
protected and you're at risk if you're a
health worker you're at risk of you if
you've got diabetes or heart disease or
or immune suppression so why don't we
just get this vaccine to where it's
needed now some countries giving lots of
vaccine and doing boosters and giving it
to some children
i find that difficult because from my
point of view as somebody who's
responsible for world issues i just
can't distinguish between a person in
the uk or a person in uruguay who's at
risk of the disease i want to see the
vaccine available to everybody so i'm
still pushing what against this business
of using lots of vaccine in a few
countries when we've got the shortage
especially because this virus is
constantly changing and new variants are
emerging quite regularly so we have to
have a worldwide approach to it and not
a country by country approach
david always good to see you hope you
and yours are well uh dr david nabarro
they're from the w thank you very much
indeed glad to be with you
oh let's stick with the topic uh joining
us now professor mike tildesley from the
university of warwick and a member of
the sage subgroup the scientific
pandemic influenza group on modelling um
professor good to have you on the
program this morning we got quite a bit
of detail um from the prime minister
from chief medical officer chief
scientific advisor yesterday what do you
make of the plan well the two-prong plan
plan a with plan b on standby
so i think probably it's a sensible
strategy the situation we're in at the
moment of course is it's a very
different position from where we were
last year and of course we have the
vaccines which we have very high levels
of protection across the population but
of course we have much higher prevalence
many more cases in the population a lot
more people in hospital than we did this
time last year so it's really how those
two trade it off against each other as
we move into the autumn that will really
dictate the rate at which any of these
measures might be introduced so i think
it's a sensible strategy and i
absolutely agree with what david's just
been saying to you absolutely fantastic
interview um there in terms of the need
to act quickly that's the really key
thing that the point that there is a
concern it's really important that any
measures are introduced rapidly so that
if that's the case we catch this rise in
infections as it occurs and any measures
that are introduced hopefully don't need
to be in for as long a period of time in
total well you you took the words
straight out of my mouth clearly there
are there are significant differences
between september 2021 and september
2020 but the one parallel is that back
in september 2020 sage was warning the
government that they needed to act and
the government sat in its hands and that
there feels to be reading through the
minutes of the sage meeting which we
shouldn't forget took place a week ago
it seems that they are suggesting that
we need to do something right now and it
need not be locked down but some of the
smaller measures should be reintroduced
to to at least mitigate at the spread of
covet
yeah and i think you're absolutely right
i don't think there's a suggestion at
all that we're in a situation that we
need to be mandating lockdown just that
if we start to observe trends where
hospital emissions start to rise in a
concerning way then it's better to
introduce some measures earlier so that
we don't end up in a situation that we
were last year i mean i remember all the
discussions going on around the need for
a circuit breaker locked down round
about this time last year and of course
that didn't come until november in
england and then of course there was all
the controversy around what happened
over christmas so that is something we
definitely need to avoid i think it's
also worth bearing in mind though that
as we move into the autumn hospital
emissions do rise anyway even in a
non-pandemic year the nhs is regularly
put under pressure over the autumn and
the key thing for me is monitoring that
trend and comparing it to where not just
where we were last year but also where
we are in a usual non-pandemic year so
we can try to put that into context
just just on on your own particular
brief how difficult is it for people to
do accurate modelling of of the strains
that there may well be on or on on
hospitalizations or on the health
service given that we don't have data
really from last year in terms of
influenza and other respiratory
infections how how easily how easy is it
to model where we might be given that
there wasn't you know natural resistance
built up last year there were
significantly fewer infections and so on
oh this is always a real challenge and
this is why you know when we publish our
reports you'll always see that there is
a range of predictions that go into
these models now unfortunately what
often happens is that when these go out
to the media there is always kind of the
big headlines of say
sage and spy m predict 100 000 cases per
day and of course often what tends to
get predicted in the media is these are
the upper estimates of these models and
actually there is a range of uncertainty
now of course as we get more data that
certainty in these model predictions
gets that much stronger so and it is
actually quite important when we're
trying to advise the government
regarding what they might expect to see
in the winter it's really important to
have best and worst case scenarios
presented so that the government can
prepare accordingly but it's also
important to remember that when these
worst case scenarios are reported they
are indeed worst case scenarios and
they're not necessarily an expectation
as to that as to that is what we expect
to see in the winter professor toastly
good to see you this morning thanks very
much for being with us
thank you
well kovids well it's as much of a
threat to some animal species as it is
to humans
at least 18 of the 20 guerrillas at
atlanta zoo have now tested positive for
covert 19 at zoo atlanta announcing the
first positive test amongst those
western lowland gorillas after employees
had noticed they had been coughing had
runny noses and showed changes in
appetite lots of us have been there
haven't we able the zoo says it's using
antibodies to treat the gorillas at risk
of developing complications from the
virus
now it is
one month since the taliban took control
in afghanistan but what of the women
left there
our special correspondent alex crawford
spoke to them she reports now from kabul
[Music]
the taliban seem to be everywhere
mingling with shoppers controlling who
goes where and what women wear
many told us they're venturing out for
the first time since the taliban took
control and we saw no female who wasn't
covered up as the taliban want even if
it's not a decree
it's an islamic society and there is no
need to tell them to wear a hijab
we haven't had to ask them
everyone is obeying that now
behind the bustle and semblance of
normality there's a lot of uncertainty
and fear and it takes bravery to talk to
a western crew in these times
[Music]
can i talk to you at all
okay
as we walk through the market a young
woman has approached one of our team off
camera she's one of thousands left
behind when the foreign troops were
pulled out
she's too scared to talk openly to us
but travels with her sister to where
we're
staying they show us the taliban death
threats sent to their mother who's a
school principal
our main aim and work is to kill old
students
and teachers and the principal
she's not the only one to get one most
of the extended family worked for the
americans and other age groups like care
which has a british base and that means
their taliban targets
they have pictures with a former u.s
first lady and others with their british
military partners
the younger sister was one day off
finishing her thesis when the taliban
took control ending her degree hopes and
changing her life
they don't
want me because i'm a girl i don't have
the right to come out of my home without
a male
why because this is the unequality
i don't have the same right as a boy
i'm nothing for them
the families seem to qualify for asylum
status in multiple countries yet none
have answered their calls for help
why i even worked for you is
that in such kind of situations they are
not responsible they are not responding
yes
they are not hearing us
it's a waste of my work experience all
those years waste of efforts ways of
struggle waste of everything actually
right now
i even have i even carry some kind of
hate in my heart for them
we go to see a female activist who's a
mother we're calling her fatima for her
safety we met her before the taliban
took control she was running for her
life then she's still running
fatima and her family were cleared for
evacuation by the british military but
before she could get there the suicide
bomb detonated killing nearly 200
including 13 u.s service personnel
she's relying on the kindness of friends
now trying to keep one step ahead of the
taliban who vowed to kill her and her
young children
i prefer to die at sea at the hands of
human traffickers trying to escape here
then be killed by the taliban she tells
us but i'm a prisoner here right now
the taliban insist women do have
freedoms but so far the taliban version
of female freedom looks worryingly
restrictive
alex crawford sky news kabul
and there is a much more of alex
crawford's reporting of course available
on our website
did you know that if we all work
together we can really make a difference
to the air pollution around our schools
yeah we should really do that
it's a bit of a gray start to the day
mist and fog over western parts will
give way to sunshine later and through
eastern areas cloud will give a little
bit of drizzle and later on perhaps one
or two showers but generally everywhere
should brighten up there'll be a few
showers over scotland and northern
ireland these will die out as they drift
their way eastwards so taking a look at
the air pollution for today we're
looking at low levels just about
everywhere and with these rather
changeable conditions they should stay
low into tomorrow as well
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
care home leaders are concerned that
staffing shortages in the sector could
become much worse when unvaccinated
staff are barred from working from
mid-november let's speak now to sam
monahan the chief executive of mha
methodist homes sam really good to see
you this morning um you are you will
have been listening into the prime
minister the chief medical advisor uh
the chief sorry chief scientific adviser
on the chief medical officer yesterday
was there anything in the outline of
plan a and plan b that serves the
purposes of the care sector
i mean i think the uh plan is well
intentioned but there is a real gap in
it in terms of it doesn't address the
workforce crisis that we've got in the
social care sector at the moment we've
got a turnover of around 30
and it's so acute and you know brexit
has left us with a smaller pool of
workers to draw upon and we're competing
against hospitality and retail a number
of our colleagues are leaving because
they're exhausted through the pandemic
and others will be leaving because they
don't want to get vaccinated so the real
challenge is how unless you equip the
social care sector will you prevent
people having to go into hospital
because they deteriorate or become frail
and how will we get people out of
hospital
when they no longer need to be there and
could move to a care home if you don't
invest in the social care sector
sam given that we only have the full
calendar month of october you've got a
bit of november bit of september to get
this sorted i mean is there enough time
for the government to do anything to
assist
in getting staff ready or
assisting staff into the industry short
of getting rid of that requirement for
mandatory vaccination
i mean what we need to do is the
government need to add all care staff to
the list of
occupations that people can come in from
abroad to work in the uk
we need to attract staff back in through
through that route we also need to
try and keep the staff that we've got by
the government paying some form of
retention bonus for all the work and the
dedication that people have shown
throughout the pandemic and we need to
look and make sure that we have a proper
workforce strategy going forward that's
going to be about recruitment and
retaining people and developing people
in the sector so people feel this is a
place they want to come and work because
we don't need to lose any more staff and
we want to try and start attracting new
staff back into the sector
can you put a figure on it um obviously
we wait to see if the government will
add anything to that which we heard
yesterday but absent any changes the
likes of which you've just described you
know come the end of november beginning
of december you know what percentage of
posts might well be unfilled in your
organization
it's really difficult to say at the
moment as i say the kind of statistics
we've got from across the sector around
30 turnover at the moment and what i can
tell you is that there are some places
some parts of the country where what
we're having to do is limit the number
of admissions we're taking because we
haven't got staff at different times now
we're constantly seeking to recruit new
staff in and we're one of the better
players in the in the sector we pay the
real living wage so we're trying to make
our uh
ourselves as attractive as possible to
new people joining the sector
but we're really concerned that unless
the government intervene and take
measures that we will be uh lacking in
the volume of staff that we need to make
sure that we can run our services safely
and provide the quality of care that we
want to when we're dedicated to
just on that point referencing the
quality of care i mean if we're talking
about 30 turnover across the industry it
suggests
that the standard of care will will
necessarily have to drop
we i mean we will prioritize the quality
of care at all costs um and that means
then that you do have to sometimes look
at whether you can have the same number
of people in your home if your staffing
is is more limited which is why we're
having to even flow and sometimes put a
cap on the number of people we can take
in so i think the problem will be the
number of people we can take in rather
than the drop in quality uh because that
will be where where it will hit
uh sam munahan chief executive uh of mha
care homes great to speak to you this
morning thanks for joining us thank you
very much
uh time for us to have a quick look at
the weather
and it's gonna be fairly quiet uh
through this the middle of the week but
it will become more unsettled with wet
and windy conditions spreading in from
the atlantic on friday
this morning a largely dry start to the
day but dull with low clouds mist and
fog this will clear over time with
bright and sunny spells coming through
there are a few showers over scotland
and northern ireland these will drift
eastwards through the day dying out as
they go
the afternoon might bring with it a few
isolated showers in the east of the
country but it will be fine for most of
us at temperatures though creeping up
pretty high 22 or 23 degrees celsius a
little above average
for the time of the year
do stay with us coming up after the
break sergei javid has told me that
there are no risk-free decisions around
covert plans this winter i'll be getting
the thoughts of labour in the next hour
stay we are
you